on va enfoncer le clou un peu plus dans
son caddie ce matin la martinique mais
la guadeloupe également sont les seules
régions françaises à perdre des
habitants bonjour christophe basso
bonjour d'être le directeur de l'insee
martinique institut national de la
statistique et des études économiques
notre pays dit vous se dépeuple de façon
assez soutenue depuis des années c'est
bien ça et bien ça c'est bien ça est de
plus en plus le phénomène s'amplifie et
aujourd'hui on perd à peu près 3500
habitants par an ce qui est très
important sur une population d'environ
375 mille habitants c'est faire
commencer quand ce phénomène exactement
alors on a eu une bascule à partir de
2010 la grande crise 2008 2009 a eu un
effet assez marquées notamment sur la
population des jeunes qui a quitté l'île
et on a vu que petit à petit à partir de
2010 c'est bien ce phénomène simplifiée
alors c'est un cocktail plutôt explosif
pour nos populations les martiniquais
parts et puis surtout on ne fait plus
assez d'enfants scellier parce que les
martiniquais qui partent ce sont les
martiniquais qui ont entre 20 et 40 ans
ou du moins ainsi quand ils partent à 20
ans ils ne reviennent pas avant l'âge de
40 ans et ce sont des périodes bien sûr
où on est en âge d'avoir des enfants
donc c'est l'une des raisons principales
pour lesquelles on fait de moins en
moins d'enfants en martinique des
cantiques ont tout cela christophe
boisseau pourquoi partons en fait qui
part exactement j'ai commencé à répondre
voilà la plupart des personnes qui
partent ce sont des jeunes pour d'une
part pour poursuivre leurs études mais
ça c'est un phénomène assez classique
qui se déroule de plus de nombreuses
décennies cela dit aujourd'hui parmi le
départ des jeunes est à peu près 40% des
jeunes qui partent pour des raisons
économiques c'est-à-dire pour chercher
un emploi et non plus pour finir leurs
études
donc c'est quand même très important et
puis la grosse difficulté c'est que les
jeunes qui par ce sont les jeunes les
plus qualifiés donc s'ils sont qualifiés
et bien ils vont chercher des emplois
qualifiés dans l'hexagone souvent dans
la région parisienne mais pas que et
puis le roux le gros souci c'est que les
emplois qualifiés qu'ils ont ils sont
très intéressants ils sont bien
rémunérés et il n'arrive pas à trouver
une type d'emploi à peu près équivalent
en martinique ce sont des martiniquais
qui ont exprimé un moment le
désir de revenir dans le rythme alors ça
arrive oui le désir de revenir mais il
ya toujours une tradition du marié qui
avait tendance à s'exiler pendant un
certain nombre d'années puis à revenir
bien là la vraie difficulté c'est que le
retour est beaucoup plus compliquée en
raison du fait que les emplois proposés
en martinique ne correspondent pas aux
qualifications mais aussi parce que ben
les martiniquais faut aussi leur vie
ailleurs avec un conjoint qui n'est pas
obligatoirement martiniquais et pour
lequel il faut également trouver un
emploi revenons à la près 2000 ce sera
bientôt le sac à février dont ce sera le
dixième anniversaire de cette grande
grogne sociale on savait généralement
que les bars ticket partait pour faire
les études c'est à dire après le bac
vers 18 ans je vais dire comme ça au
hasard mais on avait quand même les
pressions que de plus en plus de
familles martiniquaises envoyaient leurs
enfants faire des études beaucoup plus
tôt pour être sûr des prix dans des
établissements peut-être plus paie là
bas alors faire des choses que vous avez
mesuré un os est ce que ce qu'on a pu
constater c'est que le départ l'âge de
départ est un peu plus est un peu
retardée par rapport il ya une dizaine
d'années voire une vingtaine d'années et
mais c'est en grande partie liée au fait
que le ce que l'on propose pour les
étudiants pour dans le cadre de leurs
études
c'est beaucoup plus important et
beaucoup plus qu'on dirait intéressant
pour les pour les jeunes étudiants de
commencer à poursuivre leurs études au
sein de la martinique voire d'avoir des
diplômes et ensuite de éventuellement de
les finir dans l'hexagone ou alors
trouver un premier emploi dans
l'hexagone alors christophe bassons vous
avez parlé de la martinique de façon
globale ce phénomène chez nous c'est
exactement la même la même chose apprête
à pitre en guadeloupe alors euh c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose parce que
pendant de nombreuses années la
guadeloupe n'a pas perdu d'habitants du
mans était stable y avait pas de souci
donc avait un décalage de cinq ou six
ans par rapport à la martinique et on
savait que la guadeloupe allaient perdre
des habitants cela dit depuis deux ans
la guadeloupe est parti autant la perte
d'habitants en martinique a été assez
graduel on a perdu 1000 habitants par an
puis 1005 puis 2000 et cetera que en
guadeloupe tout de suite ils ont perdu
3500 habitants à hauteur de ce que perd
la martinique aujourd'hui
alors faisons maintenant de de la
politique fiction christophe bass aux
3500 aujourd'hui qui porte à peu près
chaque année
est ce qu'on risque de voir 4004 1500
5000 alors on n'a pas de boule de
cristal c'est le déficit s'est pas tout
à fait les personnes qui partent c'est
le solde entre eux ce qu'on appelle le
solde migratoire les gens qui partent
par rapport aux gens dire qu'ils
reviennent
et puis le solde naturel le sol naturel
ce sont les naissances moins les décès
aujourd'hui le solde naturel tend vers
zéro c'est-à-dire il ya à peu près et un
peu plus de naissances à peu près 400
naissances de plus que de décès mais on
sait pertinemment que comme les
martiniquais fans - à mon enfant ce
solde naturel va baisser d'autant que la
population est vieillissante donc les
décès devrait augmenter donc ce qui fait
que ce chiffre de 3500 il devrait
perdurer pendant quelques années on ne
sait pas combien cela dit si ça continue
on va baisser beaucoup plus pour la
population
vous mesurez le retour à leur tour et on
a du mal à la mesurer il ya un certain
nombre de politiques publiques qui sont
menées qui essaye de faire revenir les
jeunes mais c'est assez compliqué on a
une étude en prévision pour essayer
d'étudier les l'immigration et voir si
les gens reviennent et si oui dans quel
contexte y reviennent mais c'est assez
compliqué sauf basso dernièrement vous
avez vu du côté de du robert et vous
parliez de la démographie dans la zone
cap nord est ce qu'on peut dire que ya
une vérité pour cap nord une autre pour
la communauté d'agglomération du centre
dramatique et une autre pour l'espace
hull ou blessés le même schéma quelles
que soient les ordres on se trouve en
martinique alors c'est pas tout à fait
le même schéma dans cap nord c'est un
peu la martinique mais exacerbée
amplifié le phénomène est amplifié parce
que l'activité économique est
relativement faible dans le nord de la
martinique
peut-être un peu un peu plus faible
encore sur sur la façade atlantique que
ça venait du côté caraïbes
donc il ya des difficultés parce que les
gens se rapprochent du poumon économique
qu'est la cacem pour travailler
donc y'a il ya des départs de ddd des
migrations entre en martinique entre les
deux ensuite il ya la cacem la casse nc
le poumon économique les gens ils
essayent de vivre là mais c'est quand
même assez onéreux de vivre loyers les
loyers les impôts locaux sont
relativement élevés
donc on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une
migration aussi des gens de la cacem
vers des zones qui sont un peu moins
urbanisées on peut plus agréable à vivre
on pensait qu'après les questions du
transport
malgré les questions et parler d'un cas
ce pilote s'était fait jour compliqué de
séverine mérat ib mais bellefontaine le
quart bécasse pilotes sont des zones
attractives du corps sain d'esprit sont
aussi des zones attractives pour des
personnes qui se rendent dans la cacem
pour travailler puis enfin il ya le se
passe au sud
mais n'est ce pas ce succès c'est plus
les plages quand même ce qu'on appelle
l'héliotropisme et là c'est plus des
gens qui sont un peu plus âgés qui vont
habiter dans l'espace au sud vous avez
parlé on a parlé des communautés
d'agglomération on a parlé de cette
étude que vous avez noué des grandes
lignes au robert avec cap nore quelles
sont les personnes qui suivent
particulièrement ce genre d'étude est ce
que les élus les politiques et viennent
vous voir pour tenter de comprendre le
phénomène et pour pouvoir prendre des
décisions qui permettrait d'inverser les
tendances
c'est la raison d'être de l'insee oui
nous sommes là pour fournir des éléments
pour fournir des chiffres objectifs aux
décideurs économiques quel qu'il soit
que ce soit des politiques comme des
entreprises aidées pour qu'ils aient une
vision de la réalité des choses sur le
territoire et qu'il puisse mettre en
place des politiques qui permettent de
développer l'activité qu est ce que vous
observez cette démarche politique de
venir vous voir pour essayer de
comprendre et d y décider oui oui à
cette démarche là en l'occurrence vous
prenez l'exemple de cap nord qui nous a
sollicités assez fortement pour qu'on
fasse un diagnostic territorial pour
qu'ils aient une
une véritable idée de ce qu'il y avait
véritablement sur leur territoire parce
que il ya toujours un prisme on a
l'impression de connaître son territoire
dans les faits quand on observe les
chiffres
eh bien il ya quand même quelques
différences et les chefs d'entreprise
tout ça on les chefs d'entreprises eux
c'est un peu différent parce que ils
s'intéressent plus aux marchés
il regarde un peu ce qui se passe
comment ça pourrait se passer si je
prends l'exemple de la construction
oui je suis sollicité pour essayer de
de voir où sont les secteurs qui des
secteurs géographiques dans lesquelles
il faudrait construire parce que la
baisse de la population martiniquaise
elle est un peu partout donc voilà il ya
des adaptations des des professionnels
aux chiffres que nous pouvons sortir
justement ces chiffres quelles sont les
données que vous pourriez données qui ne
sont pas forcément grand public et qui
pourraient aider à une vraie politique
de repeuplement avant qu'on parle
peut-être d'une immigration martinique
du repeuplement c'est très compliqué
parce que c'est toujours par être tant
qu'il n'y a pas un accroissement du
nombre d'emplois qui permet enfin d'être
d'emploi qu'on peut qualifier de traiter
de très qualifiés qui permettrait à la
diaspora martiniquaise de revenir
eh bien ça va être difficile de
repeupler la martinique ensuite il ya le
deuxième aspect qui sont des emplois qui
ne sont pas pourvus et y en a en
martinique ne sont pas pourvus malgré un
taux de chômage qui est à hauteur de 18%
la martinique est vieillissante donc il
ya des besoins pour les services à la
personne
mais ce sont des emplois qui sont assez
mal vécue par les martiniquais
parce que souvent ils sont à temps
partiel ils sont assez mal payés ils
sont dans mes horaires qui sont assez
compliquées le tôt le matin tard le soir
ou le week-end donc c'est pas très
simple et puis à côté ça ce sont pour
les emplois qui sont tenus généralement
par les femmes et puis pour des emplois
plus masculin de plus de 10 masculin ce
sont des emplois agricoles la canne à
sucre la banane et il ya de grosses se
demandent aujourd'hui dans la canne à
sucre et la banane et la main d'oeuvre
n'est pas au rendez-vous que sa
faiblesse aux dernières questions parce
que le recensement a commencé jeudi
dernier ça fera à peu près une semaine
ça se passe bien les opérations
jusque là tout se passe bien j'ai invité
l'ensemble des habitants qui sont
recensés c'est pas la totalité de la
martinique il ya simplement quatre
communes qui sont concernés par un
recensement qu'on l'appelle exhaustive
c'est à dire pour toute la population
je rappelle leur nom ce sens bien la
joue pas bouillon sainte-anne et
sainte-luce et puis après il ya les
grandes communes gandhi de plus de 10000
habitants là il ya 8 % de la population
qui est enquêté mais les habitants ont
dû recevoir un avis de la part de
hummer comme quoi ils allaient être
recensées et j'invite la population à se
faire recenser et surtout d'y aller sur
internet voilà sur internet c'est
essentiel pour nous ça serait bien qu'on
rattrape la l'hexagone il 53% des
français qui répondent par internet
aujourd'hui et les que 14% l'an dernier
en martinique il faut vraiment faire un
effort merci que sa fondation rappelle
que vous êtes le directeur de l'insee
martic merci d'avoir tu ce matin avec
nous dans son caddie bonne journée
merci